melinda coleman the mother of the late
sexual assault survivor
and advocate daisy coleman died by
suicide on sunday
the tragic news comes just four months
after daisy who appeared in the 2016
documentary audrey and daisy
died by suicide at age 23.
daisy was strong in the beginning but
then it just starts to wear you down and
she just got
really into a dark place safebae the
sexual assault prevention organization
daisy co-founded prior to her death
shared the news of melinda's passing on
instagram sunday night
writing quote we are in shock and
disbelief to share with our safe bay
family that we lost melinda coleman to
suicide this evening
the bottomless grief of losing her
husband her son tristan
and daisy was more than she could face
most days
the post went on to remember melinda as
a gifted veterinarian
devoted mother and wife and talented
bodybuilder
more than anything she loved and
believed in her children it is no
accident that she created some of the
most
gifted passionate and resilient children
our hearts are forever with logan and
charlie
logan and charlie are melinda's
surviving sons
you begin to believe that all these bad
things they're saying about you
are actually true so your image of
yourself completely changes
and you kind of become a shell of
yourself you almost see
that you know doing away with yourself
is the only way to fix things which
isn't the truth at all but
it's all you can truly see when you're
sitting in a dark corner and you're not
looking around at the white
on sunday before melinda's death the
grieving mom posted about daisy on
facebook posting several pics and
writing quote
there aren't enough i love yous i could
have said when i was holding your cold
broken dead body i held you like a baby
anyway
my baby the baby i held when you first
came into this world
it has always been my greatest honor and
joy to be your mother
and best friend mama bear the whole town
split up and decide
daisy against people that were very very
vicious
we started having issues with vandalism
it was picked up in the world of social
media that's when this erupted into a
firestorm
daisy was 14 years old when she alleged
in 2012 that she was sexually assaulted
at a house party in missouri
after a night of drinking we were you
know waiting to see what was going to
happen what they were going to find in
the investigation and if anything was
going to be done
so when it finally came out that it was
just going to be probation
it was hard to deal with the accusation
led to a felony sexual assault charge
against teenager matthew barnett
which was later dropped though he
pleaded guilty to a lesser charge
after the charges were dropped it was
just really
one thing after another like all the
drama with the
social media and then i was getting in
fights
i hated going to school i hated going
out in public
i couldn't handle anymore i wanted to
fight back with everyone and i wanted to
you know
i wanted them to believe me he claimed
their sexual encounter was consensual
and the netflix documentary focused on
the backlash daisy and her family faced
in her small town
including the cyber bullying she endured
amid the case
afterwards with all the backlash we
started having issues with vandalism of
the house
we had issues with people threatening to
to beat up the kids i lost my job
because of the case then we had
our house burned down in maryville it
was just
really really hard to believe
melinda shared the news of daisy suicide
on facebook in august
writing in part she was my best friend
and amazing daughter
i think she had to make it seem like i
could live without her
i can't i wish i could have taken the
pain from her
she never recovered from what those boys
did to her and it's just not fair
my baby girl is gone